co czuje co myśli osoba manifestowana
jesteśmy cały czas w jego myślach
jesteśmy cały czas w jego głowie
on intensywnie o NAS myśli
jego znajomi często też mogą o NAS mówić
i ogólnie gdzieś mu się przewijamy
Jak nie wiem jeśli nagrywacie tiktoki czy coś
to te tiktoki mogą mu się wyświetlać w
chorych ilościach
czasami
i ta osoba manifestowana cały czas czuje taki kontekst
takie przyciąganie
czuję że ona musi do NAS napisać
czuję że ona musi się z Nami spotkać
ona Po prostu NAS bardzo chce w swoim życiu
i to co nasz bądź nasza sp
do NAS czuje
jakie ma uczucia względem NAS to jest coś Po prostu
nie do pomyślenia
a i ym nawet Jak osoba manifestowana wie
że my ją manifestujemy to ona nie ma czegoś takiego
o boże ona mnie manifestuje
jest jakaś o tylko to jest bardziej fajnie
podoba mi się
i zazwyczaj Jak manifestowałam chłopaka
to oni byli lajk ha
ze wszystkich chłopaków
jakich mogłam zmanifestować
chciała manifestować właśnie mnie